politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 pour l'épisode
230 je suis au Bundes Stagg à Berlin mon
invité et ce soir le co-président de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande le député allemand
Niels Schmitt
es politiques
bonsoir bonsoir merci de nous recevoir
ici au bunderstag pour cet entretien
vous êtes membre du SPD le Parti
social-démocrate du chancelier olafuls
vous co présidez avec l'assante donc
avec Brigitte kleinkert le bureau donc
de l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande c'est une institution
créée en 2019 qui regroupe 50 députés
français et 50 députés allemands
pourquoi est-ce que cette institution a
été créée en 2019 une assemblée
binationale c'est unique au monde oui
c'est unique et c'était nécessaire parce
que l'idée est de d'accompagner la mise
en oeuvre du traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle
qui définit les grands axes de la
coopération fondament entre les
gouvernements
et alors nous on aimerait bien voir les
parlements mieux impliqués dans dans ces
travaux là et donc on suit
les différents projets que les deux
gouvernements ont entamé ou même temps
on veut que les commissions permanentes
des deux parts
de manière plus étroite c'est pour ça
c'est pourquoi il y a eu un accord entre
parlementaire à côté du traité entre des
deux exécutifs quelles sont les missions
exactes les prérogatives que que peut
avoir cette assemblée parlementaire
entre deux pays cet assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande par
contre constitutionnelle on peut émettre
des recommandations pour les deux
assemblées parlementaires du bout de sac
et l'Assemblée nationale
et on a pour mission de
formuler des recommandations parfois à
partir
du travail qu'on fait des groupes de
travail de la de l'Assemblée
parlementaire allemande et en même temps
on veut
harmoniser la transposition de directive
européenne dans le 3 national du côté du
rang donc je l'ai dit cette assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande elle est
composée de 50 députés français 50
députés allemands sélectionnés donc dans
les deux assemblées vous vous y avez
tout de suite voulu y prendre part dès
2019 vous étiez membre avant d'en
devenir maintenant le co-président
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez eu à coeur
cet engagement pour les relations
franco-mantes vous êtes né à Trèves
juste à côté donc de la frontière dans
le Landre du bad Würtenberg ses proches
du Luxembourg de la Moselle aussi vous
vous sentez proche de la France oui en
fait j'ai grandi dans le bas dumberg
j'avais choisi le français comme
première langue étrangère au collège et
puis au lycée et donc la relation
fondament me tient beaucoup à cœur et
c'est pourquoi j'ai trouvé fascinant de
pouvoir créer cette assemblée là
élaboré
son règlement et faciliter des approches
communs entre nos deux s'assembler élus
et je pense que le rôle des Parlement
dans l'amitié franco-allemande devrait
être renforcé et en fait il y a même un
lien un lien personnel avec
l'Île-de-France parce que mon
correspondre français lui aussi
il a grandi dans les Yvelines donc je
j'y suis fréquemment allé pour passer
mes vacances pour faire
l'aller-retour entre Paris toute carte
et on a fait on a visité tous les
monuments de Paris en prenant le RER de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc c'est c'est
voilà c'est c'est un peu le prolongement
de de cette engagement personnel Paris
donc plus de secret pour vous quelle est
l'image de la France que vous aviez
lorsque vous étiez tout petit enfant que
l'image vous aviez de l'autre côté de la
frontière qu'est-ce que vous entendiez
qu'est-ce que vous imaginiez oui l'art
de vivre la cuisine française
la civilisation française la langue
aussi bien évidemment des des grands
monuments à Paris mais aussi en province
alors sur les relations
franco-allemandes maintenant j'y reviens
on utilise souvent nous en France
l'expression de couple franco-allemand
pourtant vous en Allemagne vous
n'utilisez pas du tout c'est ce terme
quand est-ce que vous pensez d'abord de
cette expression française
je l'aime beaucoup en fait nous on vient
plutôt du côté technique les Allemands
sont connus pour être ingénieurs donc on
parle du moteur font réellement et ça ça
revient à définir la relation plutôt sur
des bases du travail à faire des de la
machine qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre en
marche alors que le
la l'expression française et plus
émotionnel
et en fait je pense que c'est pas une
question de relation technique mais
c'est vraiment un amour qui s'est créé
entre nos deux peuple et notamment les
individus des deux côtés durant et c'est
important de le voir de ce côté-là alors
la dernière réunion de l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande s'est
déroulée donc le 7 novembre dernier au
bunderstag ici à Berlin c'était la
première séance en présentiel depuis le
covid qui a dû repousser dans tous les
les réunions à distance alors comment se
passe aujourd'hui une séance plénière
quel sujet est-ce que vous avez abordé
durant cette dernière assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande
l'important c'est le contact personnel
et on était très heureux de pouvoir
reprendre pu voir les nouveaux députés
français qui ont été
des élections des deux côtés en automne
de l'année dernière c'était les
législatives en Allemagne et puis
en juin en France et c'était très bien
de pouvoir relancer nos travaux
en présentiel et le courant est très
bien passé entre les élus il a eu pas
mal de nouveaux élus notamment les
nouvelles présidentes des deux
assemblées Monsieur Madame prendre
c'était très important qu'il eut aussi
ont tissé un lien très personnel et cela
c'est c'est vu lors du dîner qui a clos
notre réunion
les débats se sont portés sur l'Europe
donc il y avait des deux ministres des
Affaires étrangères
madame colonnat a été représentée par
Laurence Boone et puis on a eu un débat
je dirais en plénière sur la politique
énergétique parce que c'est ça c'est un
sujet crucial en ce moment crucial mais
aussi qui qui
est plutôt
où il y a des désaccords traditionnels
entre l'Allemagne et la France mais
c'était très important d'aborder ce
genre de sujet aussi
en tant que coprésident du bureau donc
c'est vous qui préparez l'ordre du jour
comment et par qui les sujets sont
abordés qui décident en fait de quoi de
quoi on va parler dans cette assemblée
franco-allemande en fait c'est le bureau
qui décide de cela et on a toujours
intérêt à faire intervenir des ministres
des deux côtés cela se fait chaque fois
lors de notre de nos réunions et on a
introduit un élément plus parlementaire
avec le débat entre nous c'est à dire un
débat sur des questions d'actualité
avec des
inventeurs interventions de des députés
de tout bord et ça ça a créé vraiment
l'ambiance d'un parlement et j'aime
beaucoup cet aspect cet aspect là alors
cette réunion s'est déroulée dans un
contexte de refroidissement des
relations entre la France et l'Allemagne
plusieurs différences sont apparus aux
dernières donc ces dernières semaines
mis en lumière par les bouleversement de
la guerre en Ukraine face à l'inflation
des prix d'abord de l'énergie vous en
parliez donc début octobre la France
avec quatre 14 autres pays de l'UE
souhaitaient plafonner le prix du gaz
l'idée c'était de négocier en groupe le
prix du gaz au pays fournisseur
l'Allemagne s'y était opposé pourquoi
bon
l'Allemagne était ou le gouvernement
allemand était très sceptique à l'égard
d'un plafonnement de prix alors que
l'idée d'un achat groupé
fécondensus et l'Allemagne le soutien
pleinement
je pense que là on a trouvé un pot
compromis parce qu'il y aura donc la
possibilité de trouver aussi un moyen de
plafonner des prix du gaz mais
l'important c'était la réaction de
l'Allemagne et de la France face à la
création russe en Ukraine entre le
président Macron et le chantier chaude
il y a une harmonie parfaite en ce qui
concerne le soutien
financier politique diplomatique et
aussi militaire à l'Ukraine
on est sur la même ligne en ce qui
concerne la livraison la diffusion
d'armes
le chancelier chaude a tout de suite
repris la proposition d'Emmanuel Macron
sur la création d'une communauté
politique européenne c'est pas ça à
Prague oui et les deux présidents
accompagnés par Monsieur Tracy président
du Conseil italien et le président
uranis de Roumanie ont fait un voyage
commun à Kiev pour offrir la porte de
l'adhésion a lieu pour l'Ukraine et cela
me paraît plus important que des
frictions sur quelques sociétés
techniques qui vont être résolus dans un
cours dans un bref de lait de temps en
fait sur les grands projets d'armement
commun tels que le Scaff donc l'avion de
combat du futur on s'est mis d'accord
donc des
technique ont été résolues et ça montre
que
parfois les dossiers sont plus
compliqués
que qu'on pourrait l'attendre mais au
bout du compte il y a un accord et c'est
ça qui compte au final autre point de de
un petit peu compliqué dans du point de
vue des relations franco-allemandes
c'est la question vous commencez à en
parler de la défense européenne c'est un
projet que pousse Emmanuel Macron
fortement en France mais l'Allemagne se
montre parfois réticente la guerre en
Ukraine a bouleversé votre stratégie
militaire
en Allemagne le chancelier olafels a
lancé un plan de 100 milliards pour donc
moderniser l'armée allemande mais cet
argent sera investi en partie pour
acheter du matériel américain via l'OTAN
plutôt que pour construire les contours
de cette défense européenne alors ça
agace un petit peu parfois en France
vous ce que vous ne semblez pas
tellement emballé par des idées de
défense européenne vous privilégiez plus
l'OTAN
non c'est pas le cas en fait l'OTAN
reste le pilier de la sécurité
européenne et aussi de la sécurité de
l'Allemagne mais
le budget spécial consacré à la défense
allemande
a pour objectif de remplir les lacunes
dans nos et c'est pourquoi il faut faire
vite et cela ne contredit pas notre
engagement en matière de projet européen
comment tels que le SCAF ou le char du
futur en fait il est prévu de financer
les les prochaines étapes
de ces projets là à base de ce fond
spécial donc il n'y a pas contradiction
là-dessus mais en fait il faut acheter
des munitions des frégates et
hélicoptères sur étagère
pour
faire vite et pour pallier
sous un investissement
tenda souffert
notre armée les deux politiques
toujours avec Neil Schmitt dans le
l'hebdo-politique on va passer à la
deuxième partie de l'émission de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande et député au Bundestag
du groupe SPD sur la question de
relation internationales maintenant ni
Schmidt vous êtes le porte-parole du
groupe SPD au bunderstag sur ces
questions la position de la Scholtz avec
la Chine et très critiquée le chancelier
a été le premier dirigeant européen à se
rendre à Pékin visite avec jimping
depuis le covid ça visite a fait grimpe
c'est des dents même ici en Allemagne
les vers allemands dont la ministre des
Affaires étrangères qui a appelé à ne
pas faire avec la Chine les mêmes
erreurs qui ont été faites avec la
Russie est-ce que l'Allemagne est-elle
trop pro chinoise non je dirais que la
stratégie allemande envers la Chine a
profondément changé cela
se voit dans le contrat de gouvernement
que
les libéraux les verts et des
sociaux-démocrates
élaboré ensemble c'est un changement de
cap et très très net pour la première
fois
l'Allemagne
définit une politique sur la Chine axée
sur ce que j'appelle la Sainte Trinité
donc le triangle de
rivalité stratégique
concurrence et coopération
pour la première fois
la question de Taïwan et mentionner dans
un contrat de gouvernement allemand et
on est très clair sur la question des
droits de l'homme et pour la première
fois un chancelier allemand dans une
conférence de presse appliquant même à
énoncé des propos très très net sur ces
questions là donc c'est vraiment un
changement d'époque comme la chancelier
la Chine la politique chinoise a changé
il faut que nous nous adaptons notre
politique aussi et cela veut dire qu'on
élabore une stratégie européenne envers
la Chine il faut sortir du carcan
strictement pilatéral de notre relation
avec la Chine et il faut aussi
encluber la dimension je dirais de
rivalité stratégiques et de concurrence
technologique dans notre projet de
politique sur la Chine en même temps les
chantiers a repris la formule du
président Macron sur la souveraineté
européenne et c'est très très important
ce qui concerne la Chine parce que c'est
pas seulement une question de freiner
les avancées le progrès de la Chine
c'est pas vraiment notre tasse de thé
l'important c'est que nous démocratie
occidentale démontre au monde et à nos
concitoyens que nous sommes pleinement
capables de
créer de la prospérité économique de
garantir la cohésion sociale et un
développement durable et là il faut
investir beaucoup plus dans les
capacités de l'Europe
à innover à créer de nouvelles
technologies en matière de
d'intelligence artificielle par exemple
sur la question des relations avec la
Chine il y a ce cas du port de Hambourg
qui a été également très critiqué
l'entreprise chinoise arrachée donc 30%
du port ce n'est pas un cadeau que que
l'on fait encore une fois aux
entreprises chinoises non pas du tout en
fait il s'agit
de la participation minoritaire dans
dans une société qui gère
terminale du port d'Hambourg donc il n'y
a pas eu de transfert d'infrastructures
et c'était pour le pendant en cours très
très important d'avoir cette relation là
parce que il y a une concurrence entre
port européen et d'autre part européens
ont déjà conclu de
comparable mais il faut en tenir en
retenir une leçon très très précieuse
c'est qu'il faudrait avoir des règles
européennes là-dessus sur
la les infrastructures critiques il faut
que l'Europe
crée des règles communes pour éviter ce
genre de de course
à aux investissements chinois la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar a fait beaucoup
polémique chez nous la France insoumise
et les écologistes ont appelé au boycott
les principales villes françaises ne
souhaitent pas diffuser les matchs sur
écran géant sur les places publiques 42%
des Français disent qu'ils ne
regarderont aucun match de la Coupe du
monde ici en Allemagne ce chiffre montre
même à 70% vous qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce débat
je pense qu'il faut éviter les réponses
faciles pour écouter
la retransmission des matchs c'est c'est
très facile mais cela ne change rien au
fond des de la faire les conditions de
travail pour les ouvriers étrangers
reste un sujet très sensible et je pense
que le
vrai test de notre engagement en faveur
des trois des travailleurs c'est de bien
regarder ce qui se passera après le
championnat mondial
qui dans deux ans aura encore l'intérêt
et l'attention portée
aux conditions de travail et à la
situation je dirais politique et
économique au
Qatar c'est ça la question et est-ce que
les mêmes gens qui s'intéressent
beaucoup au Qatar en ce moment
s'intéresse
en même temps
aux conditions de travail des
travailleurs étrangers en Arabie
Saoudite aux Émirats Arabes Unis c'est
là le vrai débat et il ne s'agit pas de
de quelques facilités
la question de
d'avoir
l'arc-en-ciel
déposé
sera cela aurait été
un beau mais ce qui compte vraiment
c'est le fond et c'est la question
est-ce que le Qatar est des autres pays
du Golfe
seront plus ouverts pour un pluralisme
politique pour le 3 des travailleurs
mais aussi le 3 de s'organiser en
syndicat c'est ça ou le bas place
vraiment l'actualité internationale
c'est aussi cette cop27 qui s'est conclu
en Égypte un accord pour aider les pays
du Sud a été conclu en revanche aucun
programme pour réduire encore plus les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre n'a
été décidé est-ce que vous jugez que
cette cop27 a été un échec une déception
sûrement et un échec partiel donc il y a
eu du progrès sur la question de la
compensation des dommages
par le changement climatique mais sur la
question centrale on n'a pas eu de
progrès et c'est très très regrettable
et c'est une vraie déception le Green
Deal européen lui est toujours là mais
la guerre en Ukraine complique un peu
ses ambitions est-ce que nous pourrons
réussir à réduire de 55% nos émissions
en 2030 par rapport au niveau de 1990
malgré la guerre en Ukraine qui qui dure
oui on peut le faire l'Allemagne a
démontré qu'on peut le faire parce que
la sortie du charbon de l'usage du
charbon comme combustible pour les
centrales électriques va être accéléré
l'Allemagne devrait bientôt ouvrir la
voie à l'usage du cannabis récréatif
nous sommes très loin de cette décision
nous en France notre ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a dit je
cite la drogue est un poison qui sème la
mort et la violence vouloir légaliser le
cannabis est une défaite morale pourquoi
voulez-vous vous légaliser en Allemagne
je pense qu'il faut sortir des
généralités philosophiques sur le
cannabis
la politique du tout répressif ne
fonctionne pas ni en France ni en
Allemagne c'est pourquoi nous on veut un
4 très très rigide pour l'usage légal du
cannabis
il y aura une évaluation après je prends
ce temps pour voir si ça marche donc on
est on fait très attention à ne pas
créer l'impression que
il est
très
je dirais recommandé de de
d'utiliser du cannabis mais
il faut sortir
de l'impasse dans laquelle se trouve pas
mal de pays européens
Anna Elena barbeuk ministre allemande
des Affaires étrangères a évoqué l'idée
de réunir les deux assemblées donc
française et allemande à Versailles pour
célébrer les 60 ans du traité de
l'Élysée en janvier 2023 vous soutenez
cette proposition de votre Ministre oui
en fait l'été Parlement sont en pleine
préparation de cette événement majeur
je me réjouis de cette idée là et on va
organiser une belle fête avec le recul
est-ce qu'on peut dire que le défi que
c'était lancé le général de Gaulle et le
chancelier Conrad a denauer de
rapprocher les peuples français et
allemands avec ce traité de l'Élysée
est-ce que l'on peut dire que ce traité
a fonctionné
il a très bien fonctionné et maintenant
avec le traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle on a
élargi le champ de travail et on a très
bien intégré la relation pilatérale
fontaine dont la perspective de
l'intégration européenne et c'est ça qui
est vraiment un grand progrès je pense
bien merci beaucoup Nils suite d'avoir
été avec nous dans les deux politiques
avec plaisir merci aussi au fond
citoyens franco-allemand qui a soutenu
cette émission je rappelle Miss que vous
êtes député du bundenshtag les
co-présidents de l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemand de
politique c'est terminé pour ce soir
merci de votre fidélité très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]